you've got a very cute boy over and I've
met him a bunch of times great kid how's
he doing thanks great well you know
summer service putting a lot of time
together we're we're season ticket
holders for the LA kiss arena football
team so we go and watch those games what
happened you get punched in the mouth
yeah no that was just my soul leaving my
body that didn't that didn't sound fun
to me but I and I everyone likes
different things we enjoyed it give us a
chance to bond you were hanging out
quite a bit but I think the greatest
thing is is when you hear them in
another room playing by themselves
and they use their imagination and they
use like their pop culture you know
touch-tones so he's playing with his
action figures he's 22 years old how old
is he really he's seven years old seven
adorable kid and he's the greatest
where's little fedora he's he's dynamite
and so he's played with his action
figures I'm in the other room you know
avoiding being a father and I hear him
going uh that's right bad but we have to
get Robin herkimer's penguin lookout
it's Tom Bergeron did you really say
that so I grew from Bergeron the host of
is he on Dancing with the Stars yeah
yeah and america's funniest yeah yeah
apparently he's in a big battle with
Joker so I go running ready other route
I go Oliver watch Tom Bergeron involved
because everybody's involved ed I got
done Joker penguin mom is in charge of
the bad guys grandma grandpa her
henchmen but you know who's in charge of
the good guys right I go your dad he
goes your friend Andy Richter
I don't even get casted by kids on play
right look I wasn't really I was really
hoping that you went in and Tom Bergeron
was climbing in a wig